- [Instructor] Mr. Jadav raised
all of his students' scores
on a recent exam by 10 points.
What effect did this have on the mean
and median of the scores?
Now there's two ways
we could approach this.
One is we could come up
with a simple example
that meets the constraints,
a plausible combination of scores,
and then see what is going to be true,
which of these statements get contradicted
or don't get contradicted.
That's one technique,
and that might actually be a simpler one
if you're under time pressure
in something like the SAT.
And another technique is
to do it a little bit more rigorously.
So let's do the simple way first.
So when you say, okay,
you know, his students,
you imagine a classroom
with 20 or 30 students,
but they don't say it's 20 or 30 students.
You could imagine that it
could be three students.
And if it could be three students,
then these statements need to be true for
any of the plausible
combinations of scores.
So let's just think a simple one.
Let's just imagine that the
three students all got 80s.
And I just randomly picked those numbers
because it's very easy to calculate
both the median and the mean here.
The mean here is 80,
and the middle score here,
the median, is also 80.
So both median,
median
is equal to 80 here,
and the mean is equal to 80.
Now, if you add a 10 to all of these,
if you add a 10 to all of these,
then it becomes a 90, a 90, and a 90.
And then your median and mean
are both going to become 90.
Median is going to be equal to the mean,
which is going to be equal to 90.
So at least for this
case, which is plausible,
it's not necessarily the case
that they're talking about,
but, for this case, when
you increased by 10,
but when you increased
all the scores by 10,
both the median and the
mean increased by 10.
Now let's see what these statements say.
The mean increased by 10 points
but the median remained the same.
Well, this combination, we
just said this was plausible.
This could've been Mr.
Jadav's students' test scores,
but it contradicts the statement.
The median didn't remain the same
in this case right over here,
so we could cross that out.
The median increased by 10 points,
but the mean remained the same.
Well, once again, this little
case that we came up with,
it's plausible that that was
the scores of his students,
but it contradicts the statement.
So the statement is
definitely not true for all
the possible combinations of
his students' test scores.
The mean increased by 10 points,
and the median increased by 10 points.
Now, this combination we picked,
this particular case we picked,
this doesn't prove that this
is always going to be true,
but at least it doesn't contradict it.
So we can't cross it out just yet.
The mean and the median remained the same.
Well, we were able to
come up with this case,
which is plausible, this could've
been his students' scores,
and it contradicts this.
In order for us to be able
to select a statement,
we have to feel good that it would be true
for any combination of
scores that his students had.
So we could cross that out as well.
So if I'm under time
pressure, I'm taking the SAT,
I would definitely do this
choice and then move on.
Now I'm sure a lot of you
probably want a little bit more
of a rigorous proof that we can say any,
for any combination of scores,
the mean would increase by 10 points
and the median would
increase by 10 points.
And for that, we could do a
little bit of a justification,
borderline proof right over here.
So let's just imagine
this is the score one,
and then this right over
here is the median score.
And then we keep going,
and this is the nth.
That is the nth score right over there.
Now if we added 10 to everything,
the order isn't gonna change.
So all of these scores, these n scores,
are just gonna go up by 10.
So this is going to be S one plus 10.
And then you're gonna have S two plus 10.
And then you're gonna have
your former median plus 10.
But now this thing's
going be the middle value,
and then you're going to
have your highest value.
I'm assuming that I ordered
these from lowest to highest.
And then you're going to have
your highest score plus 10.
So if all of the scores go
up by 10, whatever was the,
kind of that median, that's
still gonna be in the middle,
but now it's gonna be 10 higher.
So your new median is
going to be 10 higher.
So hopefully this justification shows you
that for whatever combination of scores,
if you order 'em in this way,
and you need to order 'em
to figure out the middle
value, the median value,
that the median indeed would go up by 10.
I also feel good that the
mean would go up by 10.
So how would you calculate the mean?
So the mean is going to be the first score
plus the second score, all
the way to the nth score,
and you're going to divide it by n.
That is what, that is going
to be equal to the mean.
Now, if you added 10 to all of these,
if it was S one plus 10
and plus S two plus 10,
and we went all the way
to Sn plus 10
divided by n,
well, what's that gonna be?
What's that gonna be?
Well, if we take all the 10s
out, we're adding 10 n times,
so we could rewrite
this as S one plus S two
plus Sn.
And then we have 10 plus 10 n times.
So we could write plus 10 n.
And then divide that whole thing,
divide that whole thing by n.
I just rewrote this.
I just, instead of adding the 10 n times,
I just wrote 10 times n, or n times 10.
Well, this right over here,
I can instead write this like this.
This is going to be that divided by n
plus that divided by n.
And what is this value right over here?
This is your mean,
your old mean.
And 10 n divided by n,
well, it's gonna be plus 10.
So your new mean is gonna
be the old mean plus 10.
So hopefully that gives you justification,
not just using a special case to rule out,
that contradicts these other cases,
but a justification why this would be true
for all combinations of scores.
We could feel very good about this.